what are the 20 Flags uh it's in your
book you know everybody go get the book
that's just very a small piece but when
you go meet a woman what are the 20
flags that you look for
all right
you have to give all 20 but some of them
yeah the Twisted pad yeah the Twisted
Tad
okay so list was ten so number one is
daddy issues she doesn't have a good
relationship with her father if a woman
doesn't have a good relationship with
the man uh of the house the guy that you
know she's supposed to grow up with him
how do you expect her to respect and
honor you as a man in a relationship or
as a father of children if you guys are
going to have kids it rarely happens the
other problem too with the daddy issues
is uh these women tend to have
borderline personality disorder or PPT
and one of the things that is connected
with that is they have a fear of
Abandonment and they tend to act out in
ways that make abandonment certain you
know if you can put it that way I expand
on a little bit more in the chapter but
I'll keep going feminists most women
today if they identify as a feminist
they're the version of toxic feminism
where they don't actually seek any kind
of equality with men in actuality I
think we've been equal for years now for
decades even like there's really nothing
A woman can't do that a man can do it's
just that they find ways to embrace
victimhood uh you know the common
talking point is something along the
lines of well women only make 75 cents
on every dollar that a man makes but
they refuse to take into account that
well when you factor in a man's income
versus a woman's income and tend to take
more dangerous jobs work longer hours
commute further experience more
workplace injuries like I don't see any
push from feminists to move women into
coal mines and garbage trucks and oil
rigs but they push to move them into the
boardroom as positions like CEOs so
there's a bit of a disconnect if you
have a victim mindset it's kind of a
loser's mindset and whenever you Embrace
a victim's mindset you need to have an
oppressor so guess who the oppressor is
going to be you're a man it's going to
be you at some point so you know if you
want to easy certain you know happy
Pleasant life generally speaking stay
away from women that identify as
feminists
um women that compete with you
um I don't know if you've ever dated one
of these boss girls one of these strong
you know boss ladies
um but my house is bigger than yours my
car is nicer than your car I've got that
it's like look I'm not here to compete
with you I'm here to compete with myself
and if you think that I want competition
from an unpleasant woman
um you got another thing coming so I
advise guys you know especially guys
that are like me chasing Excellence put
it in Denton universe and make a lot of
money to do something with life stay
away from those boss girls that try to
compete with you uh women that keep guys
from their past around
um you ever dated a woman and she says
oh I'm gonna go out to lunch with my ex
boyfriend tomorrow or something like
that really I'm not on my watch if
you're gonna try to claim me and you
want to be in a relationship with me uh
and you don't want me to see any other
girls I'm sorry but you're not able to
hang out with ex-boyfriends from your
past no good ever comes from putting
your girlfriend or your wife in a room
with another man that she was intimate
with in her past so that's something
that you have to consider
um violence a woman that's violent you
know uh she's got violent tendencies I
wouldn't even like some guys would be
like oh well you can just make her
friends with benefits not if she starts
throwing things at you and the police
need to get called because it's not her
that they'll take away in handcuffs it's
probably going to be you yeah right yeah
so stay away from violent women uh
tattoos and piercings is always a
controversial one I would probably add
extended ridiculous dagger nails to that
now which seems to be a more common
thing today and why why is that a flag
why would that be a flag
the dagger nails are the tattoos both
well I could see with the tattoos but
the dagger Nails I mean they just scare
me yeah well there's that right but I
mean like tattoos are typically a
masculine trait right like historically
tribal masculine men would get tattooed
for those reasons so when women start to
do it uh like this like this version of
culture and society today convinces
women to be more masculine eyes and I
think that women getting tattooed now
getting sleeve tattoos and lots of
tattoos all over their bodies is a sign
of them trying to be more like men uh
historically like even when I was a kid
teenage years 20 years uh you know my
20s there was no women covered in
tattoos it was very rare like the odd I
remember I had a girl from my 20s she
had a tattoo of her heart in her bikini
line that was it and that was like oh
that's taboo sort of thing and then they
moved into the [__] stamps and it sort
of went from there but tattoos just show
a lack of taste it's like putting bumper
stickers all over a Lamborghini you just
don't do it right women are beautiful by
by Nature why would you go and like draw
all over their bodies
um let alone believe it or not what
happens between tattoo artists and women
that they tattoo I've talked to a lot of
tattoo artists and they get intimate a
lot of the times too so there's that and
Richmond should I keep going yeah yeah
no no I love it I love when I was
growing up you know whatever when I was
growing up if you like uh I'm From Italy
so you can imagine how my parents were
yeah so if if a woman had a tattoo
automatically trashy trash no good you
know not good not not good to be uh
mother your children that type of thing
and then all of a sudden like you said
you know the the women needed more
rights and this and that and the tattoos
and then the piercings that that's got
to be one of them too like when they got
piercings everywhere there's lots of
piercings yeah septum piston yeah all
that stuff and then if you're a
successful businessman like yourself and
others
you know when you go to a meeting or go
to dinner with somebody else who say
more successful than you that you're
trying to make a deal with or whatever
and Here Comes Your Partner tattooed up
or earring and or a diamond in their
cheek automatically in my opinion you
might as well kiss that deal goodbye
well it's like I said I mean you might
as well show up at that business meeting
without her but drive a Lambo that's
covered in bumper stickers all right
he's gonna look at you like you're some
kind of an idiot like why do you make
these choices I don't want to invite you
into this business deal right Dad yeah
it's really irrational keep going I love
him
okay well you tell me when to stop
um big Notch counts so this this notion
of the red flags is more sensible for
guys looking for a girlfriend a
long-term relationship or the mother for
their kids if you just want to have fun
uh it doesn't matter you know if she's
got experience she's been with 50 guys
it doesn't matter but the fact of the
matter is uh there's lots of studies out
there I think the teachman study is
probably the most prolific one you can
go look it up
um but they study the effect of uh past
sexual partners on a woman's ability to
pair bond in a strong way to a guy over
a long-term basis so what that basically
works out too is a woman that's been
with uh 20 guys is less able to stay
happily married to a guy than a woman
that was a virgin or maybe had one
sexual partner another component of that
study revealed that the younger they are
when they lose their virginity the less
likely they are to experience happiness
in a long-term relationship in a
marriage you know for example so a woman
that Scott again any sexual partners
from the age of 14 is a worse Choice
than a woman that lost her virginity at
23 stayed with the same guy for seven
years you met her at 30 and she's got
one notch count right so it's something
that you have to contemplate that's a
very uncomfortable conversation
especially in today's world because when
you start saying well I don't like
promiscuous women then women start
saying well you're a misogynist or why
do you hate women or if men can do it
then why can't women do it too and the
fact of the matter is they can do it and
they do do it it's just if you're a
smart guy and you're going to invite a
woman in your life you're better off
being sensible about selecting a better
mate it's a better choice right women
that have more notches higher instances
of STDs abortions they generally bring
kids and toes from past relationships
because I've had so much sex plus
there's a baggage issue right you know
for a fact that if you're my age and you
date a woman around my age she's got a
lot more baggage than a woman that's 21
years old that's probably been with
nobody or maybe one guy
there's more of he hurt me he cheated on
me he you know he did this to me they
don't really deal with that stuff they
like to put it in a burlap bag it's like
an invisible brick I say that they write
words on it like uh resentment or guilt
and they put it in a burlap bag and they
carry it around like it's some sort of
prize nobody sees it nobody cares and
they don't want to put it down and walk
away from it so Notch counts is
something to consider as well you want
to continue yeah and and told those what
they're the one with you and then you
decide okay this is the one and that bag
that she's been carrying that you can't
see it all comes out you have to carry
around yeah yeah exactly you get the hit
with it now what what about their
friends around them you know you meet a
lot of women
they got all these drama subtle friends
and they tell their friends especially
nowadays with the phone and social media
everything that goes on and they ask
your opinion you know you know you're
rich I mean you know you have the
background approve it but then they have
to hear from 20 other people that's the
same question to 20 other people when
they just asked you
because like it's as if they want to
hear that what they had originally
thought was right
then they go around to these dramacital
friends and and do all this craziness
and with yeah so I call that their
committee their committee so so all
women have a committee but they like to
run ideas up the flagpole and see if
their committee solutes it or not
um you see this a lot of the times
online on discussion forums like Reddit
for example would be a good example uh
there's even these sub forums where
these these women sort of collaborate
together and they're like I have this
problem with my boyfriend and he doesn't
want to do that sort of thing and what
does everybody think and it's like the
committee then piles in so it could be
an in real life committee where it's
their girlfriends the you know the gals
that they hang out with and they drink
wine or they go out from time to time
and have dinner it could be an online
committee but at the end of the day all
women have a committee and ideally if
you're the right guy and you're strong
and you're virtuous and you know how to
lead the relationship women will tend to
abandon that committee and enter your
frame and be a complimentary life so I'm
not saying that you need to tell her to
abandon a committee but if she has one
you want to make sure that it's a
reasonable committee not a bunch of
angry men-hating purple-haired feminists
that are just going to tell her to dump
you and move on to the next girl because
you can always do better I feel rich I
feel like the committee always is
they're the ones that are they hate
their lives so if they see that their
friend is somewhat happy but you know
everybody's got problems in their
relationships they're like okay yeah no
that's not good you should dump them
tomorrow this isn't good because they're
miserable
yeah yeah like misery loves company and
a lot of the times you know because
women are hypergamous they want to get
their best option they don't always want
their girlfriends to be happy though
which is kind of funny I don't think
women see this until they actually see
it at some point but
it's not always good for a woman to
always rely on a committee of women
especially when you consider the source
you know if the sources they've been
divorced three times or she's got three
kids from two different fathers
I'd be asking questions like really
these are the people that you rely on
for your life advice so there's that to
consider too yeah Rich that's a big one
that's a big one because I have a lot of
friends in this situation you got any
tips on how you would go about saying to
that individual hey honey uh you know
drop the committee yeah you know these
people that you're hanging around with
that are talking to all the time that
you tell everything in the planet to and
you take their advice and then it turns
into a wreck at home
what are some tips for like a guy who
maybe has a kid or two and how do you
just somewhat break that committee
because that's some that's like uh going
against world war three
it can be you know if you try to break a
woman up from her friends it it can turn
into something quite dramatic I wouldn't
encourage to turn it into a battle even
as a result of some sort of negotiation
because whenever you try to negotiate
with women it just results in obligated
compliance which later on down the road
ends up in resentment towards you so you
know I think the best way to handle
stuff like that is to be a guy on your
purpose you're putting a dent in the
universe or doing something of some
significance in the world she sees that
she sees that you're influential she
sees that you're competent she sees that
you've got a great social network you do
cool things you've got a boat you travel
you're that guy and all you have to do
is say hey I don't take women seriously
that do this anytime a woman does
something that is perhaps red flag based
or potentially tied into red flags all
you have to do is like
um if she likes that nightclub you know
for example right then all you have to
do is say look you know you you want my
commitment you've asked to claim me I
don't take women seriously that go out
to nightclubs every weekend let her
decide what to do from then you know if
she keeps doing it then you know what
you need to do you just move on and use
replacer sort of thing or you just spend
less time with her you don't take her
seriously you keep your arms length so
you would be able to do the same thing
with a committee you know I don't take
women seriously that's that spend time
hanging around with people that offer
terrible advice that live terrible lives
you know might be their way to handle
something like that but that's all you
have to do but when they come home with
it or they get off the phone with it
I've seen probably five six marriages
they've had kids they were getting along
first you know the the honeymoon phase
yeah then they get to know each other
you know and then the girl is constantly
on the phone telling them everything you
know in-house she's not going out and
the guy would would say like you know it
doesn't really have enough balls but he
says in a nice kind of way hey you know
look who you're talking to and taking
advice from and the woman would not and
then they end up in a custody battle
alimony yeah that's why you got a vet
for all that before you put babies in so
that's a mistake that men make is first
pretty girl that touches their pee pee
they get excited Let's Get Married let's
have a honeymoon let's have a big party
they don't have a lot of experience like
they don't think about red flags like
most of the guys that read my book and
leave a review you know the most common
comment I get is I wish I saw this [__]
20 years ago I wish I saw this [__] 20
years ago yeah so I can't put your
friends in a time machine and send them
back to vet for a better woman so it's
it's almost impossible to do after
you're married so this is something that
you have to take seriously when you're
thinking about having kids if you want
to invite a woman in your life and set
healthy boundaries because that's all
you're doing you know if you you know if
I'm dating a woman and I see three four
months in she's getting bad advice from
loser women that have terrible lives
that have nothing to show for it then I
would just simply say something along
the lines of hey you know I know that
you like me sort of thing and I dig your
Vibe and all that sort of stuff but I
don't take women seriously that surround
themselves with losers might be you know
the way they handle if you want to make
a strong statement right but if you but
if you went for that
people you know if you went for the
[__] and you got nailed and you're
stuck in it is it better just to walk
away from be done with it or argue for
the next 30 Years
yeah
um that's a great question and I do get
a lot of people that book me for
coaching consults to talk about that and
there's never an easy answer
um what I've found is a lot of the guys
that have a lot of money and are real
busy with their life they might be
running multiple businesses they don't
care they just call it a loss they've
got their four kids out of the way the
marriage isn't working out the wife is
too difficult to be around or she's not
attractive you know to him anymore he
knows he can do better maybe he is doing
better you know at that point then it's
just un untie the knot pay your dues you
know give up half of what you know
whatever you have in most places in the
world and start a new life again a guy
that's worth 40 million dollars that has
to give away 20 million isn't that big
of a deal to him he knows how to make
that money back but if a guy is like got
a nest egg with the family and a bunch
of kids and they've been together for 12
years and he's worth a million and a
half including the value of the house
and all that stuff that's when guys
start to get sketchy right that's when
they're like worried because oh [__] you
know I'm only going to be worth half a
million dollars by the time I've I've
done all this and paid all the loyal
lawyer fees and everything so both
foreign fees
and yeah and then you got the kid thing
and and you know what when what happened
in this example and uh you know and you
you have a whole you know your website's
beautiful I mean you have everything on
there and you can learn more on this
just you know there's a little question
with the kids you know when you do that
so you're worth that you know 1.5 and
you have a kid and you know the woman's
gonna go with the you know I want full
custody
then you have to deal with that
situation too and I keep harping on this
because I know a lot of people going
through it and you're the guy I mean
this is the guy yeah I I actually just
finished a course on divorce and I put
it on my teachable website because a lot
of people were asking me about divorce
so you can find that there it's it's
it's it's kind of a step-by-step on how
to untie the knot Without Really you
know ruining your life too badly you
gotta understand that the deck is
stacked up against you if you're a guy
um you know one of the most I
eye-opening conversations I've ever had
with the lawyer is I just thought okay
well marriage isn't working out all this
just untie the knot you know we'll go to
court and figure this out and he's like
whoa whoa whoa stop you don't want to go
to court if you have the penis you're
going to lose
what yeah you're gonna lose if you have
the penis like that's how I think like
hadn't had it feminism equalize the
playing field like don't like women keep
saying that they're you know they have
equal rights and they want more more
rights more rights but why why is a
lawyer telling me that if you have a
penis you're going to lose you know so
if you're a father then you're at a
disadvantage so this is you know this is
one of the many areas in life that men
don't contemplate or consider because
when you get married you take vows you
know sickness and health and richer and
poorer and happiness and whatever it's
like you know you just think that you're
doing the right thing and it's good it's
good to go forever but women initiate
more than 80 percent of divorces now
it's not men that are leaving marriages
it's mostly women right so when men
leave it's actually really bad but when
women leave it's sometimes because
they're bored or they think they can do
better because their committee convinces
them of that so you got to be very very
careful with women I mean like having
the right woman in your life can change
your life for the better it really can
but inviting the wrong woman can utterly
destroy you if you're not careful I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out